you
[Music]
I work at our studio and I'm also our
studios person on the board of directors
of the art consortium so I'm here today
in a dual capacity and what I want to do
is give you some idea of what the our
consortium is helping to make happen in
in medicine and pharma so there our
consortium we are a a nonprofit
organization organized under the Linux
Foundation with three goals I mean we're
here to promote the growth and
development of our and the our community
to support the our foundation the people
who who develop our and take care of it
and also that enable the use of our in
in large scale operations and
organizations so what you see here are
the companies that are presently members
of the our consortium I particularly
like to point out Genentech Roche which
has a new member joined the consortium
just this year and I think in part at
least their membership was inspired by
some of the events that I'm going to
tell you about today so how do we
accomplish these goals we do it by
supporting projects and initiatives that
are mostly community initiated we go out
twice a year with a call for proposals
and we award grants to proposals that
are accepted so far in the three years
or so that the consortium has been in
existence we have an awarded over seven
hundred and forty thousand dollars in
grants directly to community members
who've submitted proposals we sponsor
conferences and working groups and other
community initiatives like our ladies
and we also help to organize what we
call working groups which are generally
community initiated projects that need
organization and some time consensus
building so working groups are the way
to try to organize the resources of the
the our community under the sponsorship
of the consortium to get something done
that maybe you can't do on your own or
in your own company or with a small
group so what I'm going to be talking
about today are all our consortium
working groups in process so what's
going on
and and well before I move on let me
emphasize that these initiatives that
I'm that I'm talking about here are not
something that's you know with thought
up by the Board of Directors of the our
consortium these are really grassroots
community started projects that were
just come to fruition through the
enthusiasm of the art champions and
various companies throughout the you
know throughout the world and who
managed to organize and get the people
who are their their employers and
supervisors it's excited about what
they're doing so let's look at some of
these so first is our in pharma so our
Pharma started out last year envisioned
as an annual conference to kind of
complement to this this huge gathering a
small kind of almost working group with
the kind of environment where there's
just people there to get actual work
done and make progress the conference
itself is summarized here you can see
reading left to right what you should
notice is the organizing committee was
was made up of people from lots of
different pharmaceutical companies and
device companies you can see in the
middle graph there that there were even
more companies who were attending the
conference
we had keynote speakers from the FDA so
the FDA involvement and the word cloud
over there gives you an idea of some of
the things that interested them in
particular shiny was on the minds of
almost everybody more than half of the
talks that SHINee mentioned them in some
way or another so just to emphasize that
what I'd like to show you here are a
couple of projects that were presented
at this at this hour Pharma conference
and in particular this bio warp comp
application from Roche it was written up
in the in the our views blog you can see
it under how to build the shiny truck
it's a hundred thousand lines of code
and and what you should take away from
here is that is is a production shiny
application that totally permeates all
of the regulatory tasks that go on in
order to get a drugged-out so here we
have you can see here that they have
they're advancing the use of our and
shiny in an environment that is
extremely important to how Roche
operates another talk that was that was
presented at the same conference our
pharma also by a Roche person emphasized
the kind of environment that they're
putting together there and and it gives
you some insight into the the kind of
nitty-gritty steps that need to get done
in order to go through their workflow
you know in particular they call out the
creation of tables and particular
formats that have to go into regulatory
submissions a pipeline for producing
those tables
have to have a modular framework to keep
that all happening in a dynamic way so
shiny and the pharmaceutical industry
are you know it it's it's an extremely
important and embedded part now of how
they're doing drug development a
parallel initiative this is another
working group organized about the same
time this project was awarded last year
initiated through this that psi is a a
worldwide organization of statisticians
in working in the pharmaceutical
industry and they had a special message
methods working group and what they're
trying to produce is a validated hub for
our packages validated in a way that's
particularly important for the
pharmaceutical industry so what does it
mean you know validation can mean lots
of things and what they're struggling
with is to come up with a a concept and
a workflow to help people build packages
and repositories that would contain just
those packages that are validated
according to their kind of a particular
environment in their company so what
they'll do what they're the goals are in
the beginning is to come up with an idea
of validation that seems appropriate for
the regulatory environment that they're
in to develop a concept of risk that
might be associated with a package and
to provide standards for for how to go
about validating packages and hopefully
it will result in perhaps a a a
repository that's out in the open that
will contain packages that have been
validated this way but I think more
importantly companies will use it behind
their firewalls to create repositories
have packages that are meaningful
validated meaningfully meaningfully
validated according to their particular
company standards so this is a big deal
you can see that it's these are just a
sample of some of the companies that are
involved and it takes you know it goes
across the spectrum of the
pharmaceutical industry oh I'm I'm very
hopeful that this kind of thing will set
a precedent for other kinds of
validation in different industries
I think perhaps people working in
financial organizations will find this
of use they'll have to change the
details but with any luck we will be
able to produce something that would be
easy to propagate throughout different
industries and and hopefully the our
consortium could be of help in making
that happen now in a parallel effort
that's going on is the last year all we
also started an are in medicine
conference and originally I thought you
know why one conference why not one
conference to deal both with pharma and
medicine but the the the two groups were
we're very very adamant that they all
needed their own space and as it turns
out it would not have worked that just
have one conference because these um
these working groups are really working
at a level of detail that's specific to
the particular kinds of problems that
they're solving so they are in medicine
2009 18 was really focused on clinicians
and clinical uses of our it's something
that I did not expect we had many of the
attendees were MDS PhD MDS who were
either teaching themselves are or in
some cases are in statistics all at the
same time
and here are a couple of examples of the
kinds of applications that they were
talking about this was presented by Rob
tipsy Ronnie of Stanford and what you
see is a very practical problem of
predicting blood plaited lip usage a
tremendously
you know valuable resource people give
their blood for this and they only have
the the packets platelets are only
usable for three days so they have about
a five days shelf-life two days for
getting everything in the system and the
graphs there you see are indicative of
the kind of waste over time so there was
a tremendous amount of enthusiasm not
only to help the human problem of saving
this valuable resource but for saving
money did not have these things go to
waste and the solution that they came up
with which is up and running right now I
believe still in parallel with the
original system was to forecast the the
prediction of how many units to order so
what they did was they changed the you
know the nature of the question while
they were working and it came up that it
was turned out to be a kind of standard
convex optimization problem a linear
programming problem solved I think they
used it using the c VX r package in R
which is really its own kind of dsl for
formulating and solving convex
optimization problems and they're
hopeful that they'll be able to save a
considerable amount of money so this
package is the link there you can see
the the actual analysis but the package
CVX are I think might be of use to many
of you and
the next application here I think is
particularly interesting for a group of
people that you know data scientists or
used to machine learning and what what
we have here are fast and fugle trees
there a special highly restricted kind
of decision tree it's a it's a standard
one way to look at it it's a standard
classification algorithm but it's highly
optimized for decision making so you can
see that every branch of the tree
terminates in at least one one leaps so
there's there's a decision to be made
and this is the kind of thing that is
particularly appealing to doctors who
who have to do a kind of very quick
decision making and what they'd like to
have is a tool that is sophisticated can
help them make the good decision but
it's not complicated and easy to explain
and interpret so these trees seem to be
doing pretty well and they provide an
example of you know almost every
statistical inference problem can be
conceptualized as a decision problem and
sometimes going back and forth between
the two when you're doing this kind of
analysis can be really fruitful and I
think what you'll see with this fast and
frugal tree kind of approach is that you
don't need necessarily the best
algorithm in order to to make the you
know to have a successful outcome you
don't have to have the thing that
perfectly beats everything else on the
ROC curve what you need to do is have an
algorithm that's good enough to make the
right decision so this this is a I like
it because it's at the interface of
machine learning decision-making
very you know in a fast and dynamic
environment and I think it could be
helpful for for all data scientists to
to delve deep enough into a problem to
see whether it can be conceptualized as
a decision problem and and not
necessarily a mechanistic you know
mechanistic approach to seeing how to
grind through a solution so the package
itself FF trees is up on cran and you
know I've review a lot of packages or
packages every month I am I blog about
that and I particularly like this one
because of the extensive documentation I
I would like to offer it as an example
of an R package where it seems to me
that the authors put almost as much work
or maybe more working to the
documentation that into the package
itself so I encourage everybody look at
that and you can see what I have here is
a diagram that's a standard one out of
their vignette they took a lot of
attention to presenting the work and
helping people think through the
analysis that they're presenting so I I
highly recommend that now I want to say
a couple bit of you know a couple of
words about what we might be looking at
for for 2019 this was comes from Joseph
Chu an MD at the neonate neonatal
intensive care facility the
Massachusetts General Hospital for
Children and he describes this this
actually is an email he sent to me where
he calls it his glorified chart review
program his process for chart review so
there are there physicians out here yes
so I'm sure then you'll relate to this
kind of thing
not only his sense of humor but it's
pretty amazing the amount of
sophistication that he has put into
taking data from the epic you know the
the system that is it given that they
have
work with and getting it into a place
where he can manipulate it with tidy
techniques and put it out there in terms
of flash board you know flex dashboards
and and reproducible reports so I think
this is a kind of thing that's setting a
standard for doing like reproducible
medicine at a micro level at the doctor
individual clinician level what's up I
hope that we can learn a lot more from
Joseph's participation in the organizing
committee for 2019 another group that's
doing incredibly interesting and
prolific work with SHINee is a Cleveland
Clinic department of quantitative health
services all of these are different risk
calculators shiney base risk calculators
that they have up online all of these
different diseases they're up there for
everybody here's an example of one with
you know the disclaimer don't take this
as medical advice but it's a beautiful
kind of thing that can help anyone who's
interested in the disease and their
particular or you where they might be at
risk can access again it's all shiny
based and these are production obviously
these are production applications up
there you know 24/7 so I'm hoping in
fact that we will be able to interview
some of the people involved at this and
I'll publish it on the our views blog
when that happens and then a final a
final example of analyzing glaucoma
there's is anybody here ever taken
visual field tests yes so so glaucoma is
a as a disease that you know one of the
leading causes of blindness prevalence
is about 4% in the population of people
40 to 80 years old so I mean
there and it's a degenerative
progressive disease you know it your
optic nerve deteriorates so one of the
ways they measure this is by making you
take this visual field test so you sit
there and you got your eyes in one eye
at a time focused on the dot in the
center and you got this little clicker
in your hand and it's really
nerve-wracking because what you're
supposed to do is click every time you
see a flash of light and you know the
first thing that happens is you say
where's that flash going to come from so
the flashes of light are randomly
distributed around your visual field and
the most annoying part is is that they
vary in intensity so time sometimes it's
a sharp speck and sometimes you don't
even know that you really saw it but
what they're doing is measuring the
differential light intensity so your
sensitivity to the changes in light at
various parts of the visual field and
there's something called a humphrey
analyzer and what this does is mat like
54 sections of the visual field 52 if
you take out where your blind spots are
and it produces a number so you get an
individual number for a test and what
you see here are time series in these in
these little boxes because they're they
represent longitudinal data for a
patient and what these statisticians are
doing burr Chuck at Duke and Warren at
Yale is they're building models to
predict the progression of the disease
by analyzing the changes in these visual
field records using spatial statistics
in a very sophisticated way because they
they need to measure the nearness not
only in terms of where these boxes are
adjacent to each other but how they
actually go into the optic nerve which
is not you not the same it's it's a it's
a different kind of mapping so they do
that and they're using these packages
Womble are and
new SP CP package and they've developed
models for the progression of the
disease again at an individual level so
this is the kind of thing that if you
had this disease you might go to your
your physician and say would this be
useful in tracking the progression of
glaucoma for me over over the you know
the course of my lifetime so you can
find that you can find a series of three
blog posts written on our views
describing this in some considerable
detail and of course the packages and
the statistics speak for themselves you
can find them on cran well that's
basically what I want to say and I want
to leave you with an observation and a
call to action the observation is that
all of these efforts are accomplished by
both people and and organizations
getting Bob involved in something bigger
than themselves
so when you think about the our
consortium you could you could think
about it as kind of the gateway for
companies to become involved in the our
community so just as you may write
packages and contribute to the community
in various ways this is the possibility
for companies to organize contributions
in a way that are much bigger than an
individual can mount on his or her own
efforts so help us keep up the momentum
get involved if you can your company
doesn't have to be a member of the art
consortium in order to join a working
group and that's down where the action
happens so that's it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]